what are those teenagers mutants
ninjas turtles
uh just think about your retirement
caught off the trail of re-watching the
previous two ninja turtles series i've
been itching for more of these
characters since it seems like it's
incredibly rare for them to have a bad
adaptation
i remember hearing about this animated
movie a year ago i'm thinking just from
the clips of batman saying the toby meme
alone that it would be kind of
you know kid friendly and toned down
it's pizza time i mean he's wearing the
blue costume and his voice by troy baker
which just made me think of the lego
batman stuff or batman unlimited
the turtles themselves haven't been
particularly dark or gritty since the
80s cartoon reinvented them from their
vengeance obsessed self-serious original
takes and i was fine with that
because kids should be able to enjoy
these characters just as much as i can
as a depressed adult that's desperately
clinging to the last vestiges of
childhood hope i have as the world
repeatedly denies me the only thing i
want in life but then i sat down with a
few friends recently and we threw this
on
expecting a laugh and then suddenly
oh [ __ ] geez
that was a little unexpected but yeah
that's probably as hard as they'll go
it's only a pg-13 movie it's not like
whoa okay this movie's a bit out there
and
i absolutely dig it i was caught off
guard by just
how much i liked this movie considering
all the other dc amu movies tend to feel
a bit dry and boring to me
particularly all the damien wayne
pushing that goes on or the way
everything is
kinda like new 52 but worser god they
ruined quarterbacks so bad
hey guys can we like decide which ones
of these are canon
and like stick with it no okay all right
but hey at least those are out of the
picture now
so i went into this one with relatively
low expectations
i felt like dc's animation hasn't been
as special since brave and the bold
ended
with some minor exceptions but this
movie coming out in 2019 gave me some
hope
as a batman and ninja turtles fan i feel
like this movie represents my favorite
parts of both
but best of all it pulls off the
delicate balancing act
of representing a more beloved
mainstream version of these icons while
also knowing
just how much to do a little differently
the story follows four sewer dwelling
action figure salesmen as they hunt down
their nemesis
the shredalizer to the streets of gotham
city new jersey
of course gotham's badass vigilante
protectors would want to keep the peace
on their turf
so the two groups fight because you know
that's how the [ __ ]
crossover has always got to happen you
gotta have them fight and then they team
up but then they team up to face off
with more ninjas than you can throw a
shuriken at
all right violence is not a crucial part
of batman or turtles
it's obvious that both can exist without
the blood and gore and they do that
quite often but you have to admit
it's not something that clashes with
either of them if handled well
seeing this movie go for such a blunt
and hard-hitting direction with its
action was shocking in the best way
i've always wanted to see more dark and
gritty batman stories with the blue
costume
as a kid i hated this look but as an
adult i see the charm and the idea of a
more lighthearted batman being faced
with dark subject matter is interesting
usually when batman's stories take a
dark route they make sure
he's dark too to fit with that world but
this one's a more light-hearted take
juxtaposed against some pretty gruesome
[ __ ] and the tmnt are a franchise that
works with a variety of tones
you can do a lighthearted turtle story
just as easily as a dark and gritty one
and both
work that's a story that has reinvention
and reiteration built in
so it's hard to truly get them wrong
although it's still
possible you ain't a ninja no
i am shinobi you're a full-fledged
mutant hottie
do not call me mutant or hottie but hey
let's say you didn't get into these
characters from the darker takes
and maybe you're a fan of the 80s
turtles or some of the lighter takes on
batman like adam wester brave and the
bold this one's still got something for
you too
i love how the characters are handled in
this movie this is a neutral enough take
on the adolescent jiu jitsu tortoises to
feel familiar to fans of
any take on them you can watch this
version of them directly after most
other
interpretations of them and still get a
sense that they're the same characters
their character designs take visual
elements from multiple cartoons
the initials on the belt buckles with
the 80s show the expressions and stature
of the 2003 cartoon
donatello looks a bit more like his 2012
series counterpart
but beyond that they just all have the
personality traits that we know and love
from these guys
even leonardo feels well utilized as the
leader in serious one
reigning in the antics and ninja
skateboarding bullshittery of his three
brothers
he's the one who feels most comfortable
interacting with batman because they
share a lot of common traits
being they're so disciplined and stoic
compared to their respective teams
i know i caught a lot of [ __ ] in my last
turtles video for saying leo tends to be
the most boring but i want to clarify
that i mean
when he's not used well you either
really need to double down on him being
the serious leader type and taking care
of the others
or you can make him more like one of the
guys and let him have fun and be a
goofball too
i just felt that the 2003 show didn't
lean far enough into either category and
ended up with a version of him that just
felt like he didn't socialize well with
the rest of them and mostly just barked
orders at them or got angry at life
which i still somewhat relate to we have
a more contemporary version of shredder
as our main villain alongside a whole
cast of batman villains for him to shake
his head at
[Laughter]
hate gotham i like how this shredder is
badass enough to beat batman
one-on-one granted he had to kind of
cheat to do it and barely made it out of
there but he proved he's no pushover
though i still think i prefer him as an
adorable little space-faring war
criminal
which reminds me one other part of the
previous tmnt video
to follow up on i found someone who was
willing to make me a plushie of utrom
shredder
special thanks to onigako store on etsy
for giving this to me at a price that
didn't break the bank
i love how he turned out and if you want
one
i had two made so if you want your very
own one-of-kind squid samurai space
monster
display them on a shelf cuddle with them
in bed or use them as a paperweight or a
doorstop
or you can surgically graft them into
your stomach cavity for a frighteningly
accurate cosplay
link's in the description
as for senor batman and his bat familia
i appreciate that they allowed batgirl
and robin to have a part in this story
to even out the ratio of the crossover
without them it could have easily felt
more like
ninja turtles movie featuring a bit part
by batman
and i appreciate how well they blend the
kind of villains and schemes you'd see
in a turtle story
with those of a batman story turtles are
always going up against outlandish and
conceptually
insane foes because that's exactly what
they are
while batman is always about preserving
order in his city and making sure gotham
doesn't suffer at the hands of ambitious
madmen
we get a healthy dose of both of those
things simultaneously
by taking those batman villains and then
making them
outlandish and conceptually insane
more than they already were gassing up
all these bad guys with mutagen
may turn you off a bit but they confirm
in the movie itself this isn't permanent
so why not enjoy the crazy while it
lasts oh [ __ ] they got tom kenny back as
penguin that's awesome
and lastly i appreciate what this movie
did with batman
my least favorite take on batman is the
all-powerful know-it-all
demi-god vigilante who can do anything
by himself and has
all the answers all the time the version
of him where he's finishing everyone's
sentences for them because he's so smart
and acts like he knows better than
everyone
i hate that smug bastard i like a batman
that's capable of being overwhelmed and
has to
face odds that worry him a little i also
like a batman that's sometimes second
guessing himself because he needs a
little reassurance from his friends
and most importantly i like a batman
that has friends
i don't like the anti-social my mission
must be faced alone don't help me
batman thankfully batman versus the
beegees goes more of the route i
personally enjoy for the character
where he's kind of a grouch but not
unreasonable this isn't the time for
pizza
[Music]
he's willing to accept help when he
needs it and he's not constantly
distrustful of every person he meets
seeing him and leonardo bond and compare
notes on martial arts was a lot of fun
and after the turtles have proven
themselves he drops the hard-ass act and
celebrates a victory with them
i think it's impressive that the
characters themselves aren't
self-serious grim dark takes
but the villains are that contradiction
really sells you on the difference
between them and i feel like that nuance
isn't really seen in a lot of these
movies usually it's a silly villain
against silly heroes or a dark and
gritty villain against
sepia tone punisher style heroes this is
the first animated superhero movie i've
seen in quite a while where i personally
felt like the direct
target audience batman v tmnt dawn of
decapitations
is made for people who grew up with both
of these characters
but don't mind seeing those characters
and the story mature a little along with
them
it has enough love for the classic and
more heartfelt visions of them to speak
to your inner kid
but also enough of the raw violent [ __ ]
to make your adult self cheer at the tv
watching this with a group of friends
was a blast and got a lot of excited
reactions
i recommend you find some nerdy
homebound companions
settle down in a discord call and have
yourself a movie night with the boys
and now a word from our sponsor redneck
ed
astro monster show is a satirical genre
mashup
an arcade style beat-em-up set in a
crazy hand-drawn world
where you play through an offbeat story
with multiple endings
rustic fantastic development studio and
101 xp publishing team
are excited to announce a new punchy
title you play as redneck ed a mechanic
who gets swept up in intergalactic show
business while searching for his missing
face
the game features electrifying gameplay
with non-stop waves of enemies
arena fighting upgraded abilities and a
chance to get a behind the scenes
glimpse of the inner workings of the
most sadistic game show in the universe
one that comes packed with an
action-packed plot surrealistic art
style and tons of clever easter eggs
the game is currently in development so
stay tuned for more updates
[Music]
you